Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你一直想知道如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. Without a merry entrance Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会为你提供所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。没有Marianne Trent的开场，你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》。
Thank you for listening. I know from speaking with many of you that it can feel incredibly disheartening when we are coming up in the field of psychology and perhaps people are having multiple application cycles to becoming a clinical psychologist or maybe even other types of psychologists too. And you feel like you're getting interviews but not getting the result, not getting the job that you desire. And sometimes
感谢您的收听。通过与你们许多人的交流，我知道当我们在这个领域不断努力，却可能面临多次申请临床心理学家或其他类型心理学家职位却屡屡受挫时，会感到非常沮丧。你觉得你参加了面试，但没有得到想要的结果，没有得到你渴望的工作。有时，
the feedback can be varied. It can be about performance in interview. It can be about, you know, academic skills and resources needing strengthening. And sometimes people just feel that they're not even getting shortlisted for interview. And it can be really disheartening. It can make people feel, maybe this isn't for me. Maybe I should give up. Maybe I should do something different. And I guess when I was an assistant psychologist, it could feel like I was a little bit piecemeal, really,
反馈可能会多种多样。可能是关于面试表现，可能是关于需要加强的学术技能和资源。有时人们甚至觉得连面试入围的机会都没有。这真的会让人感到灰心。它会让人们觉得，也许这不适合我。也许我应该放弃。也许我应该做点别的。我想，当我还是助理心理学家时，感觉就像是在拼凑碎片，
trying to piece things together and convince people that I was going to be a great trainee clinical psychologist. And certainly I was one. You know, I did reasonably at that. And I loved my assistant roles. But you might have heard there's a new kid on the block, the CAP, the Clinical Associate in Psychology. And you might be like, I don't really know what that is. I don't know how that would work. I've kind of heard it, but I never quite remember what the initials are. Cap. So just imagine it's a cap you're wearing. And so I thought it'd be really lovely to get someone along to talk to us who is themselves a CAP but also works at university helping to
试图把事情拼凑起来，并说服别人我将成为一名出色的临床心理学实习生。当然，我确实做到了。你知道，我做得还不错。我很喜欢我的助理角色。但你可能听说过这个领域的新成员——CAP，即临床心理学助理（Clinical Associate in Psychology）。你可能会想，我不太清楚那是什么。我不知道它是如何运作的。我听说过，但总是记不住首字母缩写。CAP。所以把它想象成你戴的一顶帽子（Cap）。因此，我想邀请一位既是CAP，又在大学里帮助
train future CAPs too. I have invited Elise along who is herself a qualified CAP but also works in academia helping to train future CAPs at Plymouth University. So with no further ado, let's get on, let's meet Elise and see what she and I have got to say. And I will look forward to catching you on the other side. Welcome along to our guest today, Elise Dyer, who is a clinical tutor and a lecturer on the MSc CAP programme at Plymouth Uni. Hi Elise, welcome along. Hi, hi, lovely to be here and lovely to meet you. You too, thank you so much for joining us. So for those who don't know what the CAP initials are, could you tell us a little bit about that please? Yeah of course it's a new program it's Clinical Associate Psychologist MSc program most universities in the UK now offering this program it's a collaborative MSc apprenticeship program
培训未来CAP的人来和我们聊聊。我邀请了Elise，她不仅是一位合格的CAP，还在普利茅斯大学从事学术工作，帮助培训未来的CAP。那么，废话不多说，让我们开始吧，去见见Elise，看看她和我有怎样的交流。我期待在节目后半部分与你相见。欢迎我们今天的嘉宾，Elise Dyer，她是普利茅斯大学MSc CAP项目的临床导师和讲师。你好，Elise，欢迎你。你好，很高兴来到这里，也很高兴见到你。我也是，非常感谢你的加入。那么，对于那些不知道CAP首字母缩写含义的人，你能为我们介绍一下吗？当然，这是一个新项目，是临床心理学助理硕士项目。英国大多数大学现在都提供这个项目，这是一个合作的硕士学徒项目。
NHS funds this program so NHS services work with universities their local universities to provide this um apprenticeship program it's 18 months and apprentices apprentice caps train with us um plymouth university and they spend two three days in their workplace learning on the job if you like so they get a chance to practice what they learn in their lectures. That sounds brilliant it's really great to know that such a program exists that you can be funded to do an MSc and also learn really valuable skills and get that clinical experience at the same time? Absolutely, absolutely.
NHS资助这个项目，所以NHS服务部门与大学、当地大学合作提供这个学徒项目。它为期18个月，学徒CAP在我们普利茅斯大学接受培训，他们每周花两到三天在工作场所进行在职学习，这样他们就有机会练习在讲座中学到的知识。这听起来太棒了，很高兴知道有这样的项目存在，你可以获得资助去攻读硕士学位，同时还能学到非常有价值的技能并获得临床经验？绝对是，绝对是。
I think it's a brilliant opportunity really for people, psychological graduates. So only psychological graduates, I'm afraid, can apply to these programmes because you are trained in clinical skills and psychology degree is viewed as a foundation to build on those skills. And ideally, apprentices should have a couple of years of experience in the field as well. It doesn't have to be paid experience but it's ideal for them to have some clinical experience as well. The program was developed to offer opportunity to especially people who cannot get on the clinical psychology program doctorate because as you know it's incredibly competitive and there are a lot of psychology
我认为这对心理学毕业生来说是一个绝佳的机会。恐怕只有心理学毕业生才能申请这些项目，因为你接受的是临床技能培训，而心理学学位被视为建立这些技能的基础。理想情况下，学徒还应该在相关领域有一两年的经验。不一定是带薪经验，但有临床经验是最好的。该项目的发展是为了给那些无法进入临床心理学博士项目的人提供机会，因为如你所知，竞争非常激烈，而且有很多心理学
graduates and experienced clinicians and working in ap posts or other posts trying years and years and years to get onto the doctorate. But unfortunately, it's not happening. So we get those people applying to clinical associate psychology programs to become a CAP. Because CAP skills, essential skills, are quite in line with clinical psychologists skills as in the core competencies are providing assessment formulation intervention and consultation so competencies skills to be able to work with people indirectly providing indirect clinical skills, if you like. So in that sense, it's quite similar to clinical psychologist competencies.
毕业生和经验丰富的临床医生在AP岗位或其他岗位上工作，尝试多年才能进入博士项目。但不幸的是，这很难实现。所以我们有这些人申请临床心理学助理项目，成为一名CAP。因为CAP的技能，核心技能，与临床心理学家的技能非常一致，即核心能力是提供评估、制定方案、干预和咨询，也就是能够与人合作的间接临床技能。所以从这个意义上说，它与临床心理学家的能力非常相似。
But the main difference is CAPS are semi-autonomous practitioners. So CAPS must be supervised by a qualified clinical psychologist or a psychologist applied psychologist that had changed recently it initially it was a clinical psychologist but it has changed now it's an applied psychologist so it could be counselling psychologist or any other applied psychologist in the service can supervise the CAP. So semi-autonomous practitioners. So that's the main difference. Thank you. So it's like it sounds like it's kind of assistant work, but with much more structure and, you know, more, I don't know, more, it's more applied. It's more of an applied profession. Absolutely. More applied, more hands-on, and a bit more autonomy
但主要区别在于CAP是半自主从业者。所以CAP必须由合格的临床心理学家或应用心理学家监督。这一点最近发生了变化，最初是临床心理学家，但现在变了，是应用心理学家，所以服务部门的咨询心理学家或任何其他应用心理学家都可以监督CAP。所以是半自主从业者。这就是主要区别。谢谢。听起来就像是助理工作，但结构更严谨，而且，你知道，更应用化。这是一个更具应用性的职业。绝对是。更具应用性，更亲力亲为，而且比助理心理学家有更多的自主权，
compared to assistant psychologists, I suppose, because CAPS, again, under clinical supervision, can provide a variety of tasks in a service, assessment formulation intervention running group groups um yeah you know doing um integrative therapies because they are trained in variety of therapeutic models um so they could really provide those interventions to their clients in their specific services um so and because they are trained in a specific service there is depth of knowledge there um i guess compared to assistant psychologists because assistant psychologists are usually just psychology graduates whereas caps
我想，因为CAP在临床监督下，可以在服务中执行各种任务，如评估、制定方案、干预、主持小组，嗯，你知道，进行综合治疗，因为他们接受过各种治疗模型的培训，所以他们确实可以在各自的服务中为客户提供这些干预措施。而且因为他们是在特定的服务中接受培训，所以那里有深厚的知识储备，我想与助理心理学家相比，因为助理心理学家通常只是心理学毕业生，而CAP
as well as doing psychology undergrad degree they they train in this specific program, 18 months of program. And they go through a quite robust learning process, really. They have, for instance, they have 119 knowledge, skill, behaviors. They train in, they learn and they demonstrate in order to graduate as a CAP. So by the time they complete the programme, they have various skills and competencies that I guess takes them a step ahead, if you like, compared to other professions at AP level. It sounds it sounds brilliant and actually it sounds like something i would have really really liked um when i was an aspiring clinical psychologist myself
除了攻读心理学本科外，他们还接受这个特定项目的培训，为期18个月。他们经历了非常扎实的学习过程。例如，他们有119项知识、技能和行为要求。他们学习并展示这些内容，以便作为CAP毕业。所以当他们完成项目时，他们拥有各种技能和能力，我想这使他们比AP级别的其他专业人士领先一步。这听起来太棒了，实际上这听起来像是我在自己还是有抱负的临床心理学家时会非常非常喜欢的东西，
because i did feel a little bit de-skilled you know i felt like i didn't really have a thing you know you know and it is hard to get therapy experience when working as an assistant. I found certainly at the time, I think things have changed a great deal since I, since I was coming up in the field of psychology. But I really like the sound of this program and how it trains people and it gives people experience of what it will be like ultimately, if they do go on to do doctorate but of course you might choose not to you might choose to stay as a cat because you really enjoy that absolutely absolutely again some people like you say um they come onto the program with a kind of long-term goal of okay i'll complete this program and i'll work in the field for a couple of years and i'll
因为我确实感到有点技能不足，你知道，我觉得我没有真正的专长。而且在担任助理时很难获得治疗经验。我当时确实有这种感觉，我想自从我进入心理学领域以来，情况已经发生了很大变化。但我真的很喜欢这个项目的构想，它如何培训人们，并让人们体验到如果他们最终去攻读博士学位会是什么样子，但当然你也可以选择不这样做，你可能会选择留在CAP岗位上，因为你真的很享受。绝对是，绝对是。正如你所说，有些人带着长期目标进入项目，比如“好吧，我完成这个项目，在领域内工作几年，然后
still go and apply to doctorate which is fine it's it's a choice but some people do change their mind and stay working as a cap a cap program also another difference compared to other kind of foundational level professions if you like. CAPs are trained as band five clinicians and upon qualification they work as a band six clinician in services. However, things are changing and expanding, roles are expanding in services and there are opportunities for career development and applying to band seven roles as well for instance in cornwall we have a colleague who after cap qualification secured a band seven position within the nhs and now they're performing that role um so there is that option and opportunity
再去申请博士学位”，这没问题，这是一种选择。但有些人确实改变了主意，留下来担任CAP。CAP项目与基础水平的其他职业相比还有另一个不同之处。CAP被培训为5级临床医生，获得资格后，他们在服务中担任6级临床医生。然而，情况正在发生变化和扩展，服务中的角色正在扩大，也有职业发展的机会，可以申请7级职位。例如，在康沃尔，我们有一位同事在获得CAP资格后，在NHS内获得了7级职位，现在他们正在履行该职责。所以确实有这种选择和机会。
um as well that's really interesting and really good to know and it really does help people to make you know and earn a livable wage whilst they're training as well so you'd get when you're training you get the band five but you also get your tuition fees paid as well is that right elise absolutely absolutely yes it's it's all paid yes amazing that sounds incredible um how did it come about as a as a thing as a program do you know much about the history of it uh yes uh basically uh can laid law from exeter university and he used to be a clinical psychologist lead. But if I remember right, he might be retired now or just about to. So he was receiving feedback and he was observing that a lot of aspiring clinical psychologists are suffering, if you like, not being able to get on to the program,
这真的很有趣，也很好知道，而且它确实帮助人们在接受培训的同时赚取可维持生活的工资。所以你在培训时获得5级工资，而且学费也由政府支付，是这样吗，Elise？绝对是，绝对是，是的。全部支付，是的。太神奇了，听起来令人难以置信。它是如何作为一个项目出现的？你了解它的历史吗？是的，基本上是埃克塞特大学的Ken Laidlaw，他曾经是临床心理学家负责人。但如果我没记错的话，他现在可能已经退休了，或者快要退休了。所以他当时收到反馈，并观察到许多有抱负的临床心理学家正在受苦，因为无法进入项目，
feeling really frustrated, feeling really disappointed. And we're losing. And he was thinking, well, we're losing these psychology graduates and really potentially good clinicians. So he and Mike Hutchinson from Exeter University, again, I think they started talking about how about looking into this training program where we train people to work as an associate psychologist and train them within a shorter program instead of three years doctorate program, but still give them depth of knowledge to work as a good clinician in the field. So that's how the programme started developing, really, people noticing, people in the field, clinical psychologists, because both are clinical psychologists, noticing there's a gap in psychology fields. So we could really create clinicians who can work,
感到非常沮丧，非常失望。我们正在流失人才。他当时想，我们正在流失这些心理学毕业生和非常有潜力的临床医生。所以他和埃克塞特大学的Mike Hutchinson开始讨论，是否可以研究这个培训项目，我们培训人们担任心理学助理，并在更短的项目中培训他们，而不是三年的博士项目，但仍然给他们足够的知识深度，让他们成为领域内优秀的临床医生。所以这就是项目开始发展的方式，人们注意到了，领域内的临床心理学家，因为他们俩都是临床心理学家，注意到了心理学领域存在一个缺口。所以我们可以真正培养出能够工作的临床医生，
who we can place them between assistant psychologists and clinical psychologists, because before CAPS, there was nothing in between, if you like. So that's how it was created, really, noticing that gap and witnessing psychological graduates not getting onto the programme and feeling utterly disappointed. So that's how it came about. This sounds incredible. They did a really good job there, I think.
我们可以把他们安置在助理心理学家和临床心理学家之间，因为在CAP出现之前，中间什么都没有。所以它就是这样被创造出来的，注意到那个缺口，并目睹心理学毕业生无法进入项目而感到彻底失望。所以它就是这样产生的。这听起来令人难以置信。我认为他们做得非常好。
I know last year it came as a bit of a shock in September, on the 1st of September, in fact, when the Clearinghouse announced that there would be HEE limits for funding. Is this programme part of that as well, the Higher Education England funding rule? At the moment, it is, yes. So, yeah, if people are training as a cap um yes so they need to after qualification they need to be staying and working um is it two years or three years i think it's two so initially on the first of september they said it was like a blanket from then didn't they but there'd been a lot of lobbying um and yeah it's been i think it's been overruled and
我知道去年9月1日，当清算所（Clearinghouse）宣布将有HEE资助限制时，这有点令人震惊。这个项目也是其中的一部分吗，即英格兰高等教育（Higher Education England）的资助规则？目前是的，是的。所以，如果人们正在接受CAP培训，是的，他们在获得资格后需要留下来工作，是两年还是三年？我想是两年。所以最初在9月1日，他们说从那时起就是一个一刀切的政策，不是吗？但经过了很多游说，我想它已经被推翻并
delayed um until next september to allow people a chance to um adjust you know was that as much as a surprise to the universities as it was to us in the field as well you know when they just announced that blanket ban yes although it was a surprise, a bit of a shock, but I personally think it's a good thing. I'm not going to deny. I think I agree with the idea because when you go on to a program and when you train, you really need that consolidation time to be able to really apply your skills and learning and to feel really comfortable and confident in what you learned and how you do that. And also, I must admit, the program, it's a brilliant program, but it's an intense program. It's not a breeze at all. And, you know, there's a lot of assignments to get through and a lot of skills to learn and to apply in your service so it takes its toll if you like and i think jumping from one program tiring hard work to another three years of another intense program although i haven't done clinical psychology
推迟到明年9月，以给人们一个调整的机会。这对大学来说是否和对我们领域内的人一样令人惊讶？当他们宣布那个一刀切的禁令时。是的，虽然很惊讶，有点震惊，但我个人认为这是一件好事。我不会否认。我认为我同意这个想法，因为当你进入一个项目并接受培训时，你确实需要那段巩固期，以便能够真正应用你的技能和学习，并对你所学的内容以及如何做感到非常舒适和自信。而且，我必须承认，这个项目，这是一个很棒的项目，但它是一个高强度的项目。一点也不轻松。而且，你知道，有很多作业要完成，有很多技能要学习并应用到你的服务中，所以它确实会带来压力。我认为从一个项目——辛苦的工作——跳到另一个三年的高强度项目，虽然我没有攻读临床心理学
doctorate i have friends who have done and who tell me similarly it's hard work it's it's you know it's not a walking in the path. So jumping from CAP course to doctorate would have been really hard. So I think it's a good thing that people will be forced, if you like, to take that two years breathing space and just work. Forget about training for a while and just apply what you learned. Consolidate that learning and, yeah yeah perform as a clinician if you like yeah i don't disagree that it's not a good idea um and it certainly will make people less impulsive you know thinking about actually whether this is going to be right for them and
博士学位，但我有朋友读过，他们告诉我同样的情况，这很辛苦，这不是一条平坦的道路。所以从CAP课程跳到博士学位会非常困难。所以我认为人们被迫，如果你愿意这么说的话，休息两年，只管工作，这确实是件好事。暂时忘记培训，只应用你所学的。巩固那些学习，是的，像临床医生一样工作。我不否认这不是一个好主意，而且它肯定会让人不那么冲动，你知道，去思考这是否真的适合他们，以及
whether that is something that they want to commit for but i think the issue was it took away people's informed choice didn't it initially when they said i can't do it for two years and it's like well that's not fair you know yeah you're right and it and it wasn't sort of it was just like a last minute thing it just came about but luckily they pulled back and they allowed people to apply and get onto the courses and now hopefully people have enough knowledge and they can make informed decisions from now on. Yeah and it's actually an aspiring psychologist himself who really spearheaded that campaign to get that overturned Erkan he did such an amazing job he's now secured a place on training this year as well which is incredible but it's helped so many people you know had that not happened it's unlikely they
这是否是他们想要承诺的事情。但我认为问题在于它剥夺了人们的知情选择权，不是吗？最初当他们说我两年内不能这样做时，感觉就像，好吧，这不公平。是的，你是对的，这只是最后一刻的事情，它就这样发生了。但幸运的是，他们撤回了决定，允许人们申请并进入课程。现在希望人们有足够的知识，从现在开始可以做出明智的决定。是的，实际上是一位有抱负的心理学家亲自带头开展了那场运动，才得以推翻那个决定。Erkan，他做得太棒了，他今年也获得了培训名额，这太不可思议了。但这帮助了很多人，你知道，如果那件事没有发生，他们不太可能
would have changed their their decision at that stage so you know there's a little message there that if we don't agree with things we can raise our heads and raise our hands and you know fight for fight for what we believe in but um it's interesting to know there's assignments in there as well are there exams too Elise? Yeah no exams uh but we have um we have variety of um assessments and um essays case reports. They also have, as I said, 119 knowledge, skill, behaviours that they have to demonstrate to their clinical supervisor in order to be signed off. And at the end of the programme, we have end point assessment. So what happens is throughout a year they learn all these skills knowledge behaviors an end point assessment is set as a day or in two
在那一阶段改变他们的决定。所以，这里有一个小信息，如果我们不同意某些事情，我们可以站出来，举手，你知道，为我们所信仰的而战。但是，很高兴知道里面也有作业，有考试吗，Elise？是的，没有考试，但我们有各种评估，还有论文、案例报告。正如我所说，他们还有119项知识、技能和行为要求，他们必须向临床主管展示才能获得认证。在项目结束时，我们有终点评估。所以发生的情况是，在一年中，他们学习所有这些技能、知识和行为，终点评估被设定为一天或两天，
days they demonstrate their skills and competencies that gain they gained from the program and in role plays so we have four stations assessment station and governance risk station formulation station intervention station so they go through those stations and they demonstrate role play with an actor and they demonstrate those clinical skills live and they are assessed by an independent assessor and they get their marks as a pass or fail so I guess the difference of CAP apprenticeship program is not only they write the same assignments and case reports but at the end they have that end point assessment process it's it's i mean it can be seen as a uh showcase you're actually celebrating what you're what you gained and you're showing off your skills if you like but needless to say it does create some anxiety in apprentices as well, because it's live and you're role playing and no one likes role plays.
他们展示从项目中获得的技能和能力，通过角色扮演。所以我们有四个站点：评估站点、治理与风险站点、制定方案站点、干预站点。所以他们通过这些站点，与演员进行角色扮演，现场展示这些临床技能。他们由独立评估员进行评估，并获得及格或不及格的分数。所以我猜CAP学徒项目的不同之处在于，他们不仅要写同样的作业和案例报告，最后还有那个终点评估过程。这意味着，它可以被视为一种展示，你实际上是在庆祝你所获得的，如果你愿意，是在炫耀你的技能。但不用说，它确实给学徒带来了一些焦虑，因为它是现场的，你在进行角色扮演，没人喜欢角色扮演。
I actually quite like a role play. I was an anomaly in my cohort for enjoying that. But, yeah, I can imagine that when it comes to, you know, to that the four station day um the anxieties are certainly running high but it sounds incredible and um you know doing it with actors as well i know some clinical um doctorate courses employ actors to come in and do things um on selection days and one time they got told to pair it back because they were like really wild and too like almost like traumatizing for people so they got told maybe next time don't be so we're not trying to scare our applicants um so the 18 is it an 18 month placement that runs for the duration of the course yes yeah
我其实挺喜欢角色扮演的。我在我的同届学生中是个异类，因为我喜欢那个。但是，是的，我可以想象，当谈到那四站的一天时，焦虑感肯定很高。但这听起来令人难以置信，而且，你知道，和演员一起做，我知道一些临床博士课程也会雇佣演员在选拔日来做一些事情。有一次他们被告知要收敛一点，因为他们表现得太狂野了，几乎让人们感到创伤，所以他们被告知下次不要这样，我们不是要吓唬我们的申请者。所以18个月的实习是贯穿课程始终的吗？是的。
18 months yeah so ideally you know maternity leave aside for supervisors it would be um you'd get the same supervisor running from start to finish is that ideal is that the gold standard it's absolutely ideal and gold standard but as you know in services unfortunately that doesn't always happen and sometimes it's unlucky a clinical supervisor may decide to stop working or get another job. And it does happen occasionally. It's not, you know, it's not too often, but occasionally it does happen that you can get a new clinical supervisor during your 18 months program. But ideally, of course, they would have one supervisor taking them 18 months program but ideally of course they would have one supervisor taking them through the program that would be ideal but i do know how how busy lives um and
18个月，是的。所以理想情况下，你知道，撇开主管的产假不谈，你会从头到尾拥有同一个主管，这是理想的吗？这是黄金标准吗？这绝对是理想的，是黄金标准。但如你所知，在服务部门，不幸的是，这种情况并不总是发生。有时运气不好，临床主管可能决定停止工作或换工作。这种情况偶尔会发生。不是太频繁，但偶尔确实会发生，你可能会在18个月的项目期间换一个新的临床主管。但理想情况下，当然，他们会有一个主管带他们完成整个项目，那将是理想的。但我确实知道生活有多忙碌，以及
conflicting demands work as well is there like a kind of mid-placement visit or the multiple mid-placement visits uh we we don't have visits from university as such. I think that's the difference between clinical psychology, doctorate program and CAP program. So as clinical tutors, we don't visit our tutees at all, but their clinical supervisor work with them closely. And of course, they're embedded in their service. their their manager their colleagues their MDT is you know keeping a close eye on on apprentices and work with them in order to help them and support them to gain those skills. Great and are there teaching blocks with at uni or is it done kind of just the days of the week oh it there is definitely
相互冲突的需求是如何工作的。是否有某种实习中期访问或多次中期访问？我们没有来自大学的访问。我认为这就是临床心理学博士项目和CAP项目之间的区别。作为临床导师，我们根本不会访问我们的学生，但他们的临床主管会与他们密切合作。当然，他们嵌入在他们的服务中，他们的经理、同事、多学科团队（MDT）都在密切关注学徒，并与他们合作，以帮助和支持他们获得这些技能。太棒了，大学里有教学模块吗，还是说只是每周的几天？哦，肯定有
teaching blocks when they start they have a teaching block with university and then they go to their placement and when they start their placement there is one or two days of uni days but yeah it's mainly done in teaching blocks and then service great um i feel like i'm firing loads of questions at you but i find this so interesting and i know our audience will as well are all of the placements in adult mental health services or are they across the lifespan could you tell us a bit about the nature of the placement basis please yeah sure it's all depends on which services need caps and what service and which service come to us to university saying can you please train our um some people for us some caps for us but it's across the lifespan it could be so for instance currently we are training adult mental health services.
教学模块。当他们开始时，他们有一个大学教学模块，然后他们去实习。当他们开始实习时，有一两天是大学日，但是的，它主要是通过教学模块完成的，然后是服务。太棒了。我觉得我在向你抛出大量问题，但我发现这太有趣了，我知道我们的听众也会感兴趣。所有的实习都在成人心理健康服务中吗，还是跨越整个生命周期？你能告诉我们实习基地的性质吗？是的，当然，这完全取决于哪些服务需要CAP，以及哪些服务来到大学说，请为我们培训一些人，一些CAP。但它是跨越生命周期的。例如，目前我们正在培训成人心理健康服务。
People, CAPS will work in adult services, but we also train CAMHS clinicians. So I was trained within CAMHS as a CAMHS CAP. So we now train CAMHS CAPS as well. But we also have plans for training CAP caps in learning difficulties, you know, any other any other secondary mental health. So it could be across the lifespan, elderly, working with, you know, elderly, older adults. Brilliant. So you'd know at the point that you were replying to the university, what the programme was, and so which area you might end up working in absolutely absolutely in that sense again it's different from clinical psychology program you apply to
CAP将在成人服务中工作，但我们也培训CAMHS（儿童和青少年心理健康服务）临床医生。所以我是在CAMHS内接受培训的，作为一名CAMHS CAP。所以我们现在也培训CAMHS CAP。但我们也有计划培训学习障碍领域的CAP，你知道，任何其他二级心理健康服务。所以它可以跨越生命周期，老年人，与老年人一起工作。太棒了。所以你在申请大学时就会知道项目是什么，以及你最终可能会在哪个领域工作。绝对是，绝对是。从这个意义上说，它再次不同于临床心理学项目。你申请的是
nhs service so best place to keep an eye on is um nhs jobs because these jobs are advertised by the services. So when you look at a job, you will see which service, where is that service and what they offer, basically. So you could be looking at, okay, well, CAMHS in Cornwall is recruiting CAPs, you know, apprentice CAPs to work within CAMHS as CAMHS clinicians, CAMHS caps basically or you could be looking into an advert to work in adult services or learning difficulty services so if you like the sound of working and training in that particular service and area, then please do apply.
NHS服务，所以最好的关注点是NHS工作网站，因为这些工作是由服务部门发布的。所以当你查看工作时，你会看到是哪个服务，那个服务在哪里，以及他们提供什么。基本上，你可以看到，好吧，康沃尔的CAMHS正在招聘CAP，你知道，学徒CAP在CAMHS内工作，作为CAMHS临床医生，基本上是CAMHS CAP。或者你可以查看在成人服务或学习障碍服务中工作的广告。所以如果你喜欢在那个特定的服务和领域工作和培训，那么请申请。
But if you feel like, I'm not sure, maybe I wanna work in CAMHS services, not learning difficulties, then you've gotta wait until CAMHS CAHPS opportunity becomes available. Again, that's the difference between clinical psychology doctorate and CAPS. Clinical psychology has breadth of knowledge. You have different services you're placed for about four
但如果你觉得，我不确定，也许我想在CAMHS服务中工作，而不是学习障碍，那么你必须等到CAMHS CAP机会出现。同样，这也是临床心理学博士和CAP之间的区别。临床心理学有知识广度。你有不同的服务，实习期大约四到六个月，从一个服务转到另一个服务。它可以是儿童服务、学习障碍、成人等。而CAP是在一个特定的服务中培训，所以有知识深度。如果你进入学习障碍服务，你将在那里培训18个月，获得资格后，你将在那个特定领域工作。所以你有知识深度，而不是广度。好的，所以如果你在老年人领域接受培训，你就不一定能申请儿童服务的合格CAP职位，因为这不一定是可转移的。不一定。但同样，也有关于核心技能和能力如何可转移的讨论，那些评估、制定方案，特别是评估和制定方案的技能，以及在一定程度上干预技能。所以这取决于服务，真的，没有人会阻止你申请不同的服务，即使你说你是在CAMHS获得CAP资格的。
to six months moving from one service to another. And it could be children's services, learning difficulties, adults, et cetera. Whereas CAPS train in one particular service, so depth of knowledge. If you're going into learning difficulties service, you'll train in that for 18 months and you'll, upon qualification, you'll work in that particular area if you like. So you have a depth of knowledge, not breadth. OK, so you wouldn't necessarily be able to apply for a qualified CAP role in a child service if, for example, you're training out older adults because it's not necessarily transferable. Not necessarily. But again, there are talks about how the core skills and competencies are transferable those you know assessment formulation um especially assessment formulation um skills and to a certain extent intervention skills so if it depends on service really there's no one would stop you from applying to a different service, even though, say, you're qualified as a CAP within CAMHS.
但你可以去申请任何其他服务，说，好吧，我有基础技能。我有那些可转移的技能，我很乐意接受你们的补充培训。也许可以有内部培训来增加那些额外的特定技能，以便能够在那个服务中工作。所以这种情况可能会发生，所以没有关于“你在这一领域获得资格，就不能申请任何其他服务”的硬性规定。好的，这真的很高兴知道。当人们在NHS工作网站上搜索时，他们应该搜索什么术语来寻找这些培训职位？他们可以使用搜索词：学徒（apprenticeship）、临床心理学助理（clinical associate psychology）、CAP。所以我想这些应该能搜出这些职位。
But you could go and apply to any other service saying, well, I've got the foundation skills. I've got those transferable skills and I'm happy to receive top up training from you. And maybe there could be an in-house training to add those extra specific skills to be able to work in that service so it could happen so there's no hard rules about you're qualified in this you can't apply to any other service okay that's really good to know and when people are looking on nhs jobs what terms should be these should they be searching for if they're looking for these training roles? They could use search terms apprenticeship, clinical associate psychology, CAP. So I think those should bring up those roles.
太棒了。谢谢。我想，当人们试图多了解一点时，他们可以进行全国搜索，对吧？这样他们就可以查看谁在招聘，他们在说什么，如果他们确实想了解目前周围的情况，职位要求和工作描述是什么。绝对是，绝对是。而且，我认为这对人们来说也是重要的一点。我们的项目完全是远程的，远程教学，在线教学。我相信大多数大学都提供远程教学的CAP项目。他们的NHS实习服务，所以他们必须住在服务地点附近，但他们不必住在大学附近。所以我们在普利茅斯，大学在普利茅斯，但我们有来自南安普顿地区的Southern Health，或者我们有牛津CAMHS在我们这里培训，我们有康沃尔CAMHS在我们这里培训。所以我认为在线远程教学非常有效，确实极大地帮助了人们。我认为这是新冠疫情的“一线希望”之一，不是吗？大学现在可以提供这些完全在线的项目。绝对是，而且这完全是为了提高人们的可及性，并能够适应他们的生活。你知道，我自己也是一位母亲，我知道你也是，这确实有助于你变得更灵活。绝对是，绝对是。是的，我听说你是第二届学员，你在哪里接受的培训？你能告诉我们你是否喜欢培训，你是如何发现它的，以及所有这些吗？绝对是，绝对是。是的，我是康沃尔的第二届学员，事实上我当时
Great. Thank you. And I guess, well, whilst people are trying to learn a bit more about it, they could look at doing a national search, couldn't they? So that they're looking at who's recruiting, what they're saying, what the person spec and the job description is, if they do want to have an overview of what's around at the moment. Absolutely. Absolutely. And also, I think this is an important thing as well for people. Our program is entirely remote, remote teaching, online teaching. And I believe most universities provide CAP program as a remote teaching. their NHS placement service so they've got to live nearby their service but they don't have to live near university so we have we are in Plymouth university is in Plymouth but we have Southern
在CAMHS担任兼职初级心理健康工作者，当这个机会出现时，我非常感兴趣，我申请了，我获得了职位，我非常享受培训。我做的时候它不是学徒制，它只是一个硕士学位。所以我是在CAMHS内接受培训的，我知道服务。我认识我一起工作的人。所以我已经嵌入在团队中了，这实际上非常有帮助。培训非常好。讲师来自埃克塞特大学。是埃克塞特大学到康沃尔来培训我们。
Health from Southampton area or we have Oxford CAMHS training with us we have Cornwall CAMHS training with us so I think online remote teaching is really effective and helping people greatly really I think this is one of Covid's silver linings isn't it that universities now can provide those online fully online programs. Absolutely and it's all about improving accessibility for people and being able to fit it around their lives you know I'm a I'm a mother myself and I know you are too and it just helps you to be a bit more flexible absolutely absolutely yes I understand you were part of the second cohort um where you trained could you tell us a little bit about whether you enjoyed training how you found it and all of that absolutely absolutely yeah I I was the second cohort in Cornwall and in fact I was
那是当时的情况。是面对面的。而且，是的，在我的同届学生中，我们有26个人，我们都积极性很高，相处得很好。这是一次非常好的经历，工作非常辛苦。正如我之前所说，它一点也不轻松。所以，你知道，你必须组织良好，积极性高，而且你必须掌握它，我想，才能跟上它。但是，都是很好的经历，你知道，我会一次又一次地这样做。所以这是一个可爱的经历。我其实很心动，Elise，我不撒谎。我自2011年以来一直是一名合格的心理学家。当它只是在线时，你现在还有很多机会进行同届学生联谊吗？
working as a primary mental health worker within CAMHS part-time and when this opportunity became available I was I was highly interested and I applied and I I secured the position and I thoroughly enjoyed um training um it wasn't an apprenticeship when I did it it was just an MSc uh degree um so I trained within CAMHS with and I knew service. I knew the people I worked with. So I was already embedded in the team, which was quite helpful, actually. And the training was really good. Lecturers came from Exeter University. It was Exeter University to Cornwall to train us.
因为你可能是你服务中唯一的CAP实习生。你有很多时间进行同届学生联谊吗？是的，好问题。我们有混合日。基本上，我们要求我们的学徒从他们所在的地区五六个人一组进入他们的服务。所以他们有混合学习日，他们在一起学习，我们在那些日子里为他们提供任务，他们实际上是一起完成的，所以也会有一些联谊。我们的大多数同届学生，他们所做的是，他们都创建了自己的同届WhatsApp群，然后他们总是互相发短信，你知道，交谈、联络并互相帮助，
It was back then. It was face to face. And, yeah, in my cohort, there were 26 of us and we were all highly motivated, bonded well. It was really good experience, really hard work. As I said earlier, it wasn't a breeze. So, you know, you it's it's you've got to be well organized and highly motivated and uh you've got to be on top of it i guess to be able to keep up with it um but but all good experience you know i i would i would do it again and again so it's it's lovely experience i'm quite tempted actually elise i won't lie up in I've been qualified as a psychologist since 2011. Do you get much of a chance to do cohort bonding these days when it is online only?
互相支持。所以，虽然理论上听起来可能像“哦，全是远程的，他们可能不会联谊”，但他们实际上找到了联谊的方法。太好了。我很高兴听到这个，因为实际上，当我作为临床心理学家接受培训时，甚至当我还是助理心理学家时，我最喜欢这些角色的部分就是我与同时做同样事情的人建立的关系。所以，当我们试图在上升过程中避免倦怠时，这非常重要。拥有同伴支持并在那些WhatsApp群组中做一个“墙头草”非常重要。嘿，Liz。
Because you might be the only associate training cap in your service. Are you getting much time to do any cohort bonding? Yeah, good question. We have hybrid days. Basically, we ask our apprentices to go into their service from their locality in fives or six. So they have hybrid learning days where they learn together and we provide them tasks on those days where they actually do it together so then there's a bit of bonding as well and most of our cohorts what they do they all create their own cohort whatsapp and then they always text each other and you know talk and liaise and help each
我也是。我也是。你能给我们一些关于在心理学职业生涯中避免倦怠的建议吗，如果可以的话？绝对是。我想作为心理学家，我们必须言行一致，真正拥有良好的工作与生活平衡，并确保你的界限。我喜欢“界限”这个词。所以，如果你的工作时间是朝九晚五，请务必在五点停止，关掉你的工作笔记本电脑，不要查看你的工作邮件，并真正照顾好自己。在周末留出一点属于自己的时间，
other support each other so there is is, although, you know, in theory, it may sound like, oh, it's all remote, they may not bond, but they actually find ways to bond. Good. I'm so pleased to hear it because actually, when I was training as a clinical psychologist, and even when I was an assistant psychologist, my favourite bits of those roles was the relationships I made with people doing the same thing at the same time. So it's really important when we are trying to avoid burnout on the way up. It's really important to have peer support and to be a fly on the wall in those WhatsApp groups. Hey, Liz.
与家人、朋友共度美好时光。去从事你的爱好。它可以很简单，比如去散步，呼吸新鲜空气，或者去喝杯咖啡，吃块蛋糕。只要有那些生活中的小确幸，就能让你坚持下去。我很幸运，我住在康沃尔，所以我经常游泳，特别是在这些日子里，下班后去海里跳一下，简直是天赐的。所以真正把那些时间夺回来，作为属于自己的时间，并确保你照顾好自己。是的，有条理确实有助于那种保持，比如记笔记，
Same here. same here um could you give us some of your top tips for avoiding burnout on the way and on the way up and through psychology careers if that's okay absolutely i i guess we've got to practice what we preach as psychologists really having a good work-life balance and making sure your boundaries i I love this word boundaries. So, you know, if your working hours are nine to five, please do stop at five, turn off your work laptop, do not check your work emails and really look after yourself. Have a bit of me time at weekends,
给自己设定，比如我可以，好吧，我可以在这段时间和那段时间之间读一点书。但从晚上7点到8点，例如，我和我的伴侣吃晚饭，或者在那之后我看一点Netflix，你知道，我不知道，我不知道，我在那个时间上床睡觉，绝对不考虑工作或任何事情。真正严格地在周末关机，并在工作时间内工作。我认为这非常重要。真的，真的非常重要。是的，把它划分开来。
spend quality time with your family, friends. Go and do your hobbies. It could be as simple as just go for a walk and have fresh air or go and have, I don't know, coffee and cake. Just have those little treats, simple pleasures in life to keep you going, if you like. I'm lucky I live in cornwall so i swim regularly especially these days it's just god sent really after work i just go and jump in the sea um so really claiming those times back like me times and making sure that you look after yourself and and yeah being organized does help with that kind of keeping a notebook if you like
而且无论我们认为我们在工作更长时间时是在为谁服务，我们通常都不是，你知道。界限真的，真的非常重要。我喜欢你能够潜入大海的声音。我住在英格兰中部，我对此非常嫉妒。这听起来令人难以置信。不，真的很好。我很幸运。
giving yourself say for instance i can okay i can do a bit of reading between this time and that time but then from 7 p.m till 8 p.m for instance i have my i don't know dinner with my partner or after that i'm watching a bit of netflix um you know i'm i don't know i dinner with my partner or after that, I'm watching a bit of Netflix. You know, I'm I don't know, I'm going to bed at such time and definitely not thinking about work or anything. Really being strict in a way that you switch off at weekends and be on working hours. I think it's hugely important. Really, really important. Yeah, compartmentalising it.
我们在康沃尔很幸运，这里很可爱，都搬下来吧。我可能会，我可能会考虑一下。和你交谈并了解更多关于这个令人难以置信的培训计划真是太愉快了。非常感谢你的时间。我知道人们会超级超级有兴趣了解更多关于它的信息，因为它感觉像是一个神秘的新来者。是的，是的，不，和你交谈也很愉快。我希望它确实能帮助一些人做出决定和选择，我强烈推荐心理学毕业生或需要临床心理学替代职业的人，如果你愿意的话。所以，是的，如果你有任何进一步的问题，或者如果有人想知道，请联系我。
And whoever we think we're serving when we're working longer hours, we're often not, you know. Boundaries are really, really important. I love the sound of you being able to dive into the sea. I live in the middle of England and I'm so jealous of that. That sounds incredible. No, really good. I'm lucky.
无论我们认为加班是在为谁服务，其实往往并不是那样。界限真的非常非常重要。我很喜欢听你说能潜入大海，我住在英格兰中部，对此真是羡慕不已。听起来太棒了。不，真的很好。我很幸运。
We're lucky in Cornwall it's lovely all moved down I might do I might do I might look into it it's been such a pleasure talking to you and learning more about this incredible training scheme thank you so much for your time I know people will be super super interested to learn more about it because it feels like this sort of mysterious newcomer yes yes yeah no it's been lovely talking to you too and i hope it does help some people to make decisions and choices and i highly recommend psychology graduates or people who need an alternative career to clinical psychology if you like um so yeah and do contact me if you have any any further questions or if anyone wants to know
我们在康沃尔很幸运，那里很美，大家都搬过来了，我也许会考虑一下，也许会去看看。和你交谈并了解这个不可思议的培训计划真是太愉快了，非常感谢你抽出时间。我知道人们会非常有兴趣了解更多，因为它感觉像是一个神秘的新来者。是的，是的，和你交谈也很愉快，我希望这确实能帮助一些人做出决定和选择。我强烈推荐心理学毕业生，或者那些需要临床心理学以外职业选择的人，如果你们喜欢的话。所以，是的，如果有任何进一步的问题，或者如果有人想了解更多，请随时联系我。
anything further i'm happy to respond and reply as much as possible brilliant i'll make sure i pop your details in the show notes. Do you want people to start following Plymouth University on socials? Is that a good thing to do? Oh it's it's an excellent thing to do it's one of the best universities and I'm not saying this because I work for them but no it really is a brilliant program and lovely university really and we're a really good team all you know we're happy to help brilliant I'll make sure we get the links for following Plymouth Uni in the show notes as well and tag you when this episode is coming out I've adored today I could talk to you more and more especially about Cornwall that sounds incredible thank you so much for your time today
如果有进一步的问题，我很乐意尽可能多地回复。太棒了，我会确保把你的详细信息放在节目说明中。你想让大家在社交媒体上关注普利茅斯大学吗？这样做合适吗？哦，这太棒了，这是最好的大学之一，我这么说并不是因为我为他们工作，而是因为这确实是一个很棒的项目，也是一所很可爱的大学，我们是一个非常好的团队，你知道的，我们很乐意提供帮助。太棒了，我会确保在节目说明中附上关注普利茅斯大学的链接，并在本集发布时标记你。我今天过得很愉快，我本来可以和你聊更多，尤其是关于康沃尔的话题，听起来太不可思议了，非常感谢你今天的时间。
oh you're most welcome. Really enjoyed it too. Yeah, thank you. Brilliant, thank you. Oh, thank you for listening. What an absolute pleasure speaking to Elise was and how good does Cornwall and the sea sound. We recorded this on a super hot day in August. We were both melting, which is why we decided,
哦，不客气。我也很享受这次谈话。是的，谢谢。太棒了，谢谢。哦，谢谢大家的收听。与埃莉斯交谈真是太愉快了，康沃尔和大海听起来多美啊。我们是在八月一个超级炎热的日子录制的。我们当时都快融化了，这就是为什么我们决定，
I decided to go off camera today and just do audio by the time we started filming I'd not long got back from a run and got out the shower and I was like it's just so hot I'm so hot let's just keep it and let's just keep it on audio hope that hasn't altered your enjoyment if you are watching on YouTube. So what I should say is just at the end, Elise said, oh no, I forgot to mention something. So I said I'd do it in this section. So once you are a qualified CAP, you don't have to work for the NHS if you don't want to. You can also work in academia. So you can also work in universities, which is what she had done as well so I hope that's really useful because it obviously gives you more more scope for future
我决定今天不开摄像头，只录音频。开始录制时，我刚跑完步回来，洗了个澡，我当时觉得太热了，我太热了，还是只录音频吧。希望如果你在YouTube上观看的话，这没有影响你的观看体验。我应该说的是，在最后，埃莉斯说，哦不，我忘了提一件事。所以我说我会在这一部分补充。所以，一旦你成为合格的临床心理学家（CAP），如果你不想，你不必为英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作。你也可以在学术界工作。所以你也可以在大学工作，这也是她所做的事情，所以我希望这真的很有用，因为它显然为你提供了更广阔的未来空间，
qualified work as well but how incredible does it sound I would love your thoughts around this episode if you wanted to come and join the group, which is totally free on Facebook, and do search for the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent, and in brackets it will say free group. That's how you know you're in the right place. Come and discuss what you thought to this episode. I'd love to know what you're thinking to it. Has it inspired you? Has it given you some more information?
合格的工作机会也更多。但听起来多棒啊，如果你想加入我们的群组，我很想听听你对这一集的看法。群组在Facebook上是完全免费的，搜索“Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent”，括号里会写着“free group”。这样你就知道你找对地方了。快来讨论你对这一集的看法吧。我很想知道你的想法。它启发你了吗？它为你提供了更多信息吗？
Also, if you would like to join the waiting list for the next time the Aspiring Psychologist membership opens, do check out the details in the show notes. But I have loved today. I hope you have found it really useful as well. If you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes, do drop me a line. Otherwise, do please check out the dates for the compassionate Q&As to support the DeclinSci application season. They are totally free to attend and the details for how you can attend those will be in the show notes. But if you wanted to join the free Facebook group, it will definitely be in there. So come along and join so that we're nice and ready for when they start.
另外，如果你想加入下一次“有抱负的心理学家”会员资格开放的候补名单，请查看节目说明中的详细信息。但我很喜欢今天的内容。希望你也觉得它非常有用。如果你对未来的播客节目有什么想法，请给我留言。否则，请务必查看为支持DeclinSci申请季而举办的同理心问答环节的日期。它们完全免费参加，参加详情将在节目说明中提供。但如果你想加入免费的Facebook群组，里面肯定会有相关信息。所以快来加入吧，这样我们就能为活动开始做好准备了。
I will level with you. I can't quite remember when this episode will be going live because we've got some scheduled and in the can already but the first of the live Q&A sessions is actually on the 1st of September this year when they open which is Thursday. I'm not quite sure when this episode goes out so it might be that you can watch that on replay if it is indeed after the 1st of September and I'm desperately looking around for my diary but it's not in the room so I can't I can't end that mystery but yeah it's been a pleasure speaking with you today if you find the podcast useful please do like subscribe
我跟你说实话，我不记得这一集什么时候会发布，因为我们已经安排好了一些录制好的内容，但第一次直播问答环节实际上是在今年9月1日，也就是周四。我不确定这一集什么时候播出，所以如果是在9月1日之后，你可能只能看回放了。我正在拼命找我的日记本，但它不在房间里，所以我无法解开这个谜团。但总之，今天和你交谈很愉快。如果你觉得播客有用，请点赞、订阅，
comment tell your friends and rate and review on Apple Podcasts would be absolutely wonderfully gratefully received. Come and connect with me on socials. Most places I am Dr. Marianne Trent. I absolutely adore helping you to celebrate your successes. So do please come and connect. Yeah, and I will catch up with you very soon. Don't forget the next episode of the Inspiring Psychologist podcast is available for you to listen to from 6 a.m on mondays um but don't worry it will be here when you're ready um you don't need to set your alarm for 6 a.m um i hope you have a wonderful day whatever you're up to and thank you again for being part of my world take care If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified.
评论、告诉你的朋友，并在Apple Podcasts上评分和评论，我将不胜感激。快来在社交媒体上与我联系。大多数地方我都是Dr. Marianne Trent。我非常喜欢帮助你庆祝你的成功。所以请务必来联系我。是的，我会很快和你联系。别忘了“有抱负的心理学家”播客的下一集在周一早上6点发布，但别担心，当你准备好时它会在这里，你不需要为早上6点定闹钟。希望你无论在做什么，都能度过美好的一天，再次感谢你成为我世界的一部分。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。书中充满了能帮助你获得资格的经验和教训。
So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
所以来看看吧。就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家合集》。这就是《临床心理学家合集》。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将在获得资格的道路上前进。这就是“有抱负的心理学家”播客。
With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become clinical psychologists. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我叫贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我在做错什么，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。
but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就放不下这本书了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。